ja dann fangen wir mal an meine damen
und herren wir begrüßen sie sehr
herzlich zum presseberichten
robert-koch-institutes dienstag des 23
juni heute werden wir zwei statements
haben zunächst von professor lothar
wieler präsident des robert
koch-instituts danach dr die rexroth
leiterin des fachgebiets verweilens und
nach den beiden statements sind wie
üblich ihre fragen möglich er weder
bitte ja guten morgen meine damen und
herren die ico wird 19 pandemie breitet
sich weiterhin weltweit aus momentan
stehen im zentrum des geschehens die
amerikanischen kontinenten nord und
südamerika mittlerweile sind rund 8,8
millionen fälle bekannt offiziell
gemeldet und uns wurde auch von rund
465.000 todesfällen berichtet das sind
daten die von der weko zur verfügung
gestellt wurden nahezu alle länder
berichten überfälle am 21.06 diesen
jahres also vor wenigen tagen berichtete
die who die höchste tägliche zunahme ein
neuer cupid 19 fälle das waren über
180.000 das ist in etwa dem bereich die
in deutschland in der ganzen pandemie
bislang zu melden hat die ausführlichen
fallzahlen
wie können sie natürlich finden auf den
websites der weltgesundheitsorganisation
als auch des europäischen zentrums für
krankheitskontrolle ich möchte kurz
einen kleinen vergleich ziehen was ist
weltweit im cockpit 19 geschehen zur
zeit zu beobachten
und wir kommen später auf die situation
in deutschland noch genauer amerika etwa
die hälfte der weltweiten fälle wird
momentan vom amerikanischen kontinent
gemeldet dabei sind vor allem die usa
und brasilien stark betroffen in den usa
sind es insbesondere die südlichen
bundesstaaten aktuell
die gründe dafür sind eine lockerung der
abstandsregeln obwohl die fallzahlen
dort noch gar nicht ni durchgefallen
sind und wir sehen dort unter anderem
ausbrüche in gefängnissen aber auch in
fleischverarbeitenden betrieben in asien
hier sind vor allen dingen momentan
indien und pakistan betroffen wo die
abstands beschränkungen bereits
teilweise oder auch vollständig
gelockert wurden
und hier ist der hintergrund im
wesentlichen dass die bevölkerung von
hunger und armut geschützt werden soll
auch in saudi arabien sind wir stark
anfälle anstiege der fälle im iran wird
eine zweite welle gemeldeten momentan
gründe für den anstieg hier sind auch
die lockungen trotz steigender
fallzahlen allerdings werden auch hier
die test kapazitäten erhöht sodass man
natürlich genauer in das geschehen
reinschauen kann in afrika da sind die
fallzahlen ebenfalls einem ansteigen
machen jedoch derzeit weniger als fünf
prozent der täglich gemeldeten fälle
weltweit aus hier ist noch unklar ob die
fallzahlen wirklich die realität
abbilden
wir müssen wissen dass in afrika
natürlich eine günstige demographie ist
die viele länder sehr sehr viele junge
menschen dort aber wir kennen die
dunkelziffer nicht genau hier sind in
vielen ländern geringe test kapazitäten
vorhanden und die möglichkeit der
kontakt nach verfolgung ist auch nicht
in allen ländern so gegeben wie das
natürlich zum beispiel in deutschland
der fall ist in europa ist es zurzeit so
dass die lage sich stabilisiert russland
nord mazedonien und armenien melden
jedoch neue hohe fallzahlen
das ist wichtig zu verstehen wir schauen
immer in ein zeitfenster und wir müssen
immer vor augen haben dass diese kurve
neun zentimeter ein dynamisches
geschehen ist und wie immer nur in einem
bestimmten zeitraum rein blicken
nur ein paar wichtige statements zu
deutschland bevor frau rexroth ihnen
mehr details dazu geben wird
allgemein ist es so dass wir aus vielen
kreisen keine oder nur sehr wenige fälle
in den letzten sieben tagen über mittel
bekommen haben von den lokalen
gesundheitsämtern bzw über die länder
stellen
aus 137 kreisen in deutschland wurden in
den letzten tagen sogar überhaupt keine
fälle übermittelt
aber es kommt auch immer wieder zu
einzelnen ausbrüchen in einzelnen
kreisen das ist ihnen bekannt
in den letzten wochen wurden im mittel
etwa 350 neue fälle pro tag ans lka über
die gesundheitsämter und landesstellen
übermittelt und wir sehen das seit
letztem dienstag diese zahlen wieder
etwas ansteigen und das liegt nach
unserer einschätzung an einzelnen
ausbruchsgeschehen die geschätzte
reproduktions zahl der faktor der lag
lange zeit stabil unter 1 aber in den
letzten tagen ist eher gestiegen seitdem
21.06 liegt er geschätzte werte zwischen
2 und 3 stand heute der sensitive r
wir haben zwei verschiedene werte der
eine wird auf einer basis von vier tagen
geschätzte andere auf einem basis von
sieben tagen in der vergangenheit der
sensitive erwert wird heute auf 276
geschätzt und der stabilere auf 1,83 nun
nach unserer einschätzung liegt das
daran dass die derzeit beobachteten
ausbrüche den er wert massiv
beeinflussen
es könnten auch andere gründe seien aber
das analysieren wir genau nach unserer
ansicht stehen die ausbrüche hier vor
allen dingen in der verantwortung
wichtig ist hier einzuschätzen generell
sind die erwehrte natürlich besonders
bei niedrigen täglichen fallzahlen
vorsichtig zu interpretieren denn dann
schwanden sie natürlich besonders wenn
wir einzelne ausbrüche haben wenn wir
das zusammenfassen sehen wir dass die
maßnahme in deutschland gut gewirkt
haben sie haben gegriffen und das ist
vor allem der fall
die bevölkerung eben sehr gut mitgemacht
hat und dass dafür können wir uns immer
nur alle noch einmal herzlich bedanken
und das tun wir auch weiterhin
aber eins ist wirklich wichtig wir
müssen weiterhin achtsam sein
das virus ist ja noch in unserem land
und wenn wir ihm die chance geben sich
auszubreiten dann nimmt es sich diese
chance das sieht man an den derzeitigen
ausbruch geschrieben auch die zahl der
übermittelten todesfälle ist in den
letzten wochen deutlich gesunken
das ist natürlich eine folge daraus dass
wir eben weniger infektionsfälle sehen
und weniger neuinfektionen feststellen
wir sehen aber auch dass derzeit in
höheren altersgruppen nicht mehr so
stark von kogit 19 betroffen sind und
das ist natürlich auch eine gute
nachricht die anzahl der an das
robert-koch-institut von den
gesundheitsämtern über die landesstellen
übermittelten todesfälle liegt im moment
in der regel im unteren zweistelligen
bereich pro tag
aber auch hier gibt es natürlich einen
verzug so dass wir auch weiterhin damit
rechnen müssen dass noch todesfälle
auftreten und sich das in die letzten
tage auch erhöhen kann
die behandlungskapazitäten in
deutschland sind weiterhin gut
auch für intensivbetten und
beatmungsgeräte das kann aber natürlich
ausbruchs bedingt vielleicht lokal auch
mal zu überlastungen kommen momentan ist
das aber nicht der fall
weiterhin spielen die gesundheitsämter
eine zentrale rolle bei der eindämmung
des geschehens und insbesondere darf
dabei fälle zu finden
kontaktpersonen zu managen und die
infect ketten zu brechen und infekt
schutz infektionsschutz maßnahmen
einzuleiten das ist ja diese wichtige
zentrale arbeit und wir haben den
gesundheitsämtern aufgrund dieser
hervorragenden arbeit in den letzten
wochen und monaten zu verdanken dass wir
die fälle haben reduzieren können
weiterhin bleibt ist weiter wichtig dass
wir genügend test kapazität hätten haben
damit wir in verhelfen ausbrüchen und
gezielten untersuchungen immer nachgehen
können und diese tests auch
niederschwellig angeboten werden
und da und wir müssen alle auch in den
kommenden wochen natürlich weiterhin
sehr achtsam sein um weitere ausbrüche
möglichst zu verhindern
die pandemie ist ja nicht vorbei sie ist
weltweit nicht vorbei ich habe ihn eben
einige zahlen und eindruck vermitteln
und sie ist auch in deutschland nicht
vorbei die derzeitigen ausbruchs
geschehen beispielsweise in
fleischverarbeitenden betrieben oder
auch in glaubensgemeinschaften können
über kontakt für natürlich auch leicht
die in die bevölkerung übertragen werden
deshalb ist es wirklich weiter so
wichtig dass wir uns alle nach wie vor
18 verhalten und uns an die regeln
halten also abstand halten
hygieneregeln beachten und dort wo
geboten masken tagen alltags masken
tragen ein neuer bestandteil in der
pandemie bekämpfung den haben wir in der
letzten woche eingeführt das ist die
krone waren app die haben sich innerhalb
weniger tage mehr als zwölf millionen
menschen diese app heruntergeladen und
wie sie wissen ist dass saas koch 2
virus ja bereits vor erkrankungsbeginn
übertragbar
und natürlich können hier auch digitale
tools dabei helfen und sollen den
gesundheitsämtern dabei helfen solche
infektionen früher zu entdecken und dann
infektionsketten früher zu unterbrechen
ich möchte noch mal ein wort zu den
testungen sagen wir haben wirklich sehr
viel test kapazitäten in deutschland das
ist ein riesiger vorteil und ein
wichtiger faktor bei der weiteren
bekämpfung aber diese testung sind
natürlich keine prävention wenn jemand
negativ getestet wird dann ist das
natürlich auch nur eine momentaufnahme
ein negativer test bedeutet natürlich
nicht dass man sich nicht dort
angesteckt nicht doch angesteckt haben
kann und natürlich heißt es auch nicht
dass man nicht in der zukunft sich
anstecken kann deshalb unabhängig von
den ganzen werkzeugen die wir inzwischen
haben und die uns sehr sehr hilfreich
sind und wichtig sind bitte bleiben sie
achtsam diese pandemie können wir nach
vor nur gemeinsam in der bisher
gezeigten solidarität gut bekämpfen
danke vielen dank wieder jetzt dr
rexroth leiterin des fachgebiets
surveillance im robert koch institut
ich möchte als erstes ihnen einige
bilder zeigen eine einige darstellung
aus unserem lagebericht und ich hoffe
das klappt auch dass sie die technisch
sehe der steinberg die nummer eins und
zwar ist dass die epidemische kurve die
wir unserem lagebericht haben
da sehen sie als planer fälle diejenigen
mit erkrankungsbeginn und gelb dazu
diejenigen nachmeldet datum also das ist
eine gemischte kurve aber wir denken
dass sie eine ganz gute abbildung ist
das nun wieder das infektionsgeschehen
sich entwickelt hat und die zeigt wie
harry löschung gesagt hat dass seit
mitte märz ein deutlicher
kontinuierlicher rückgang der fallzahlen
zu beobachten war
sie kennen das wochenend effekte aber
dennoch ist es immer weiter
zurückgegangen
und jetzt letzte woche haben wir einen
kleinen anstieg gesehen klein im
vergleich zur gesamt kurve aber groß für
diejenigen die betroffen sind für die
gesundheitsämter vor ort und das ist in
erster linie auf lokal
ausbruchsgeschehen zurückzuführen und
auf die dort durchgeführten reihen
testungen also das wollen wir im
weiteren verlauf noch mal ein bisschen
genauer angucken und in der zweiten
abbildung hoffe ich dass sie die
aussehen kann
sehen sie das die deutschlandkarte auch
aus unserem lagebericht und dort zeigen
wir ihnen die instanzen der letzten
sieben tage
und da sieht man eben welche landkreise
und kreisfreien städte besonders
betroffen sind und hier kommen eben vor
allem gütersloh und das angrenzende
warendorf besonders hervor in nordrhein
westfalen aber auch göttingen und
magdeburg und neukölln hier in berlin
die gute nachricht dieser karte ist was
er will er auch gesagt hat das ja
wieviel sind jetzt 137
in den letzten 7 tagen gar keine fälle
übermittelt haben das ist ein wirklich
großer erfolg ist von der bevölkerung
und den behörden vor ort und zusätzlich
auch 212 die unter 5 400 tausend fälle
übermittelt haben und wir denken dass
die lokalen behörden sehr wachsam sind
und dass wir diesen deswegen ganz gut
frauen können also insgesamt haben wir
mit dem stand heute dem 23 06 insgesamt
über 190.000 19 fälle übermittelt
bekommen
190 1862 genau und darunter waren eben
auch leider acht 1895 todesfälle und
allein am gestrigen tag uns 500 fälle
übermittelt wobei sie auch wissen müssen
natürlich mit dem wochenende dass das
nicht die anzahl ist derjenigen die dann
erkrankt sind sondern eben die wir
gestern zur kenntnis bekommen haben in
den letzten sieben tagen waren das
deutschlandweit 3899 fälle und das
entspricht deutschlandweit 4,7 fällen je
100.000 einwohner in den letzten sieben
tagen also deutschlandweit ist das ganz
gut
die zahl der gelesenen wird auf aktuell
175 1700 geschätzt allerdings ist es ein
schätzwert und wir wissen dass ungefähr
350 fälle noch auf intensivstationen
liegen
ja sie wissen auch dass die zahlen um
die genesenen dass wir das täglich alles
aktualisieren auf dem corona dashboard
wo die daten einfließen die wir von
gesundheitsämtern und den landesbehörden
bekommen und dass wir täglich auch immer
einen situationsbericht aktualisieren
aus dem diese daten kommen wo sie das
nachlesen können hier kommt immer
spätnachmittags und es auf unserer
internetseite
in der dritten abbildung die ich hoffe
dass sie die aussehen kann
sehen sie nur die verstorbenen und zwar
nach dem tag an dem sie verstorben sind
nicht an dem tag wo sie uns bekannt
gegeben wurden und diese kurve zeigt
auch wie herr wieder gesagt hat einen
deutlichen rückgang
es ist natürlich schon so dass wir
zeiten hatten wo über 250 fälle am tag
verstorben sind in einer akuten group 19
erkrankung zum glück ist dass in den
letzten tagen und wochen zurückgegangen
so dass wir hier relativ wenig fälle
jetzt im moment also tools fälle täglich
nur beklagen müssen
der anteil der verstorbenen hatte ich
schon gesagt dass insgesamt vier kommen
oder hätte ich schon seit 4,7 prozent
und auch das ist im internationalen
vergleich relativ gut
allerdings sind das trotzdem sehr viele
todesopfer im vergleich auch zu anderen
infektionskrankheiten die verstorbenen
waren im durchschnitt 81 jahre alt und
86 prozent der verstorbenen waren über
70 oder älter so 70 oder älter aber es
kann kommen natürlich auch todesfälle
bei jüngeren menschen vor wir haben 30
fälle erfahren von unter 20 jährigen
diese litten unter vorerkrankungen aber
es kommen durch auch auf todesfälle
unter menschen vor die keine
vorerkrankungen hatten ja und dann
möchte ich zuletzt noch auf die
ausbruchsgeschehen eingehen herr bieler
hat es gesagt zuletzt gibt es sehr viel
ausbruchsgeschehen die die lage
dominieren und vor ort auch massive
herausforderung bewirken und das ist
eben vor allem der landkreis gütersloh
das ist ihnen bekannt
dort sind durch rein testung in einem
fleischverarbeitenden betrieben über
1000 fälle aufgefallen also
mitarbeitende und auch zum teil an die
sich auch vorgestellt in krankenhäusern
und auch der benachbarte landkreis
warendorf ist auch betroffen so dass
dort auch deutlich erhöht die inzidenz
zu beobachten sind
in göttingen sind das eher wohnkomplexe
die betroffen sind
da sind auch ein test durchgeführt
worden
und ähnlich in magdeburg dort sind auch
wohnkomplexe betroffen da stehen sehr
viele haushalte derzeit unter quarantäne
das natürlich eine schwierige situation
ist und ebenfalls in neukölln können
hier in berlin
da sind auch initial wurde zusammenhang
mit gottesdiensten fälle aufgetreten das
wird noch genauer untersucht und dort
stehen aktuell circa 370 haushalte unter
quarantäne
also diese ausbruchsgeschehen ist es nur
beispielhaft es gibt natürlich auch in
anderen landkreisen und kreisfreien
städten ausbruchsgeschehen in den
letzten wochen hauptsächlich in eher
schwierigen sozialen bedingungen was
auch nicht ungewöhnlich ist für
infektionskrankheiten aber auch zeigt
dass es ein große herausforderung ist
vor ort dem zu begegnen
und dennoch werden natürlich auch
weiterhin ausbruchsgeschehen in alten-
und pflegeheim beobachtet allerdings
weniger viel und das ist auch eine gute
nachricht dass es gelingen kann und das
ist dort auch gelungen ist viele
ausbruchsgeschehen zu verhindern oder im
keim bereits zu ersticken
und man sollte ja vielen dank frau roth
sie können jetzt ihre fragen stellen ich
ruf gleich drei nach auf sagen sie bitte
gerne dazu an wen sie ihre frage richtet
falls wir aber feststellen dass
vielleicht für den anderen die frage
passen da ist mir natürlich auch dann
probieren wir es jetzt mit dem zdf
mittagsmagazin
ich hoffe dass rossi uns hören ach so
ich wollte erheblich angehoben und ich
selbst habe jetzt schon los bauen ja
wieder
ich habe ihr könnt mich mal gefragt bei
der zertifizierung des pcr test versuch
1,4 prozent positive fälle festgestellt
ich schriftlich haben sie dazu gesagt
die qualitätsstandards sind in
demokratien aber deutlich besser sind
falsch positiven test senken kann aber
selbst wenn wir das deutlich günstiger
machen wir vielleicht nur 0,5 prozent
falsch proteste sind das ja bei 50.000
es die am tag ungefähr durchgeführt
werden trotzdem 250 fälle das ist ja
momentan geschehen
abgesehen von den lokalen ausbrüche und
auch eine relevante zahl und dann haben
wir doch auch beobachtet dass jetzt
viele demonstrationen und
menschenansammlungen in letzter zeit ja
auch schon ausreichend zurückliegen
nichts zu größeren ausbruchsgeschehen
geführt haben
zusammen mit der insgesamt geringere
sterblichkeit und den glimpflichen teil
auch bei vielen menschen ist das nicht
doch gibt's eigentlich doch auch viele
anzeichen für eine glimpfliche
einschätzung der lage ist insgesamt
kommen und vielleicht auch zu sagen das
ganze das infektionsgeschehen wasser
stattfindet und müssen nicht an
kritischen einschätzung kommen ich hätte
aber gerne auch die frage gestellt wann
die studien ergebnisse herauskommen
präsentiert stunden da sind eine menge
fragen aber ich herzlichen dank versuch
sie zu beantworten also sie haben
natürlich recht selbstverständlich hat
jeder test bestimmte qualitätsmerkmale
ich kann dazu sagen das ist einer der
gründe warum wir ja auch gar keine
testung durch die ganze bevölkerung
machen sondern nach wie vor
anlassbezogen testen und vorwiegend
testen in einem umfeld wo wir mit
infektionen rechnen können um dann
wirklich infektionsketten auch durch
schnell zu durchbrechen und diese
qualitätsparameter werden zum einen
natürlich immer wieder verbessert zum
anderen aber wird natürlich auch
nachgetestet in bestimmten fällen um
einen besteht und ein ergebnis auch zu
validieren
die einschätzung die sie trafen
bezüglich der lockerungen und der eine
eines milderen verlauf es wir haben
eigentlich die krankheits schwere von
beginn an der pandemie ziemlich gut
eingeschätzt wenn sie sich erinnern
sagten wir zu beginn immer von fünf
infizierten werden vier krank und haben
nur milde symptome aber eben einer von
fünf wird schwerer krank das hat sich
sehr gut bestätigt durch die ganzen
zahlen die uns inzwischen vorliegen nach
den zahlen wenn ich die richtigen kopf
gehen ja so und 18 prozent der
infizierten müssen hospitalisiert werden
und wir haben einen relevanten anteil
derjenigen die dann auch aus
spezialisiert wird die dann auch im
krankenhaus auf intensivstation verlegt
werden müssen und dort auch beatmet
werden müssen insofern gibt es kein
anlass die krankheit schwerer anders
einzuschätzen als wir das von anfang an
getan haben wir wissen dass die
krankheit schwerer sehr stark vom alter
der personen abhängen also ab 50 jahren
steigt eigentlich sehr klar das risiko
schwer zu erkranken
je älter man wird vor allen dingen aber
auch von grundkrankheiten und wir dürfen
einfach nicht aus dem blick verlieren
dass wir in deutschland eine demografie
haben wir haben sehr sehr viele menschen
die alt und hoch altrich sind und wir
haben natürlich in deutschland auch eine
reihe von menschen die grundkrankheiten
haben dann also quasi das was wir als
risikofaktoren bezeichnen ist schon in
einer wirklich großen anteile bevor
einfach vorhanden also insofern gibt es
überhaupt keinen grund die krankheit
schwerer kleiner zu machen als sie
tatsächlich ist was dazu geführt hat
dass wir erfolgreich waren waren eher
die bestimmten maßnahmen diese maßnahmen
abstand halten
massenveranstaltungen eben abzusagen den
kontakt insgesamt zu beschränken und wie
sagen dass ich habe das zu anfang gesagt
wir gehen zurzeit davon aus dass die
mehrheit also gerade die die
veränderungen auch der fallzahlen als
auch die veränderungen in dem er wehrte
er nur einer von mehreren werten ist die
das robert-koch-institut sehr intensiv
betrachtet andere welchen fallzahlen
inzidenz sensibles tage sieben tage sind
sie der nutzer
wir gehen davon aus dass das
mehrheitlich von ausbruchsgeschehen
getrieben ist aber sicher sind wir uns
dann auch nicht wir schauen dass an
ich denke nicht dass die lockerungen
völlig folgenlos bleiben werden deshalb
kann nicht nur nach wie vor uns alle
darum bitten dass wir achtsam bleiben
und diese regeln einhalten wir werden
das langfristig sehen
aber es gibt eigentlich keinen grund zu
denken dass sich die krankheit nicht
wenn einzelne in solchen
massenveranstaltung demonstrationen sind
und die menschen sich nicht ein abstand
halten nicht auch andere anstecken wir
werden das in der zukunft sehen
ich kann nur alle hoffen die krankheit
oder bitten die krankheiten auch wir vor
so ernst zu nehmen wie sie ist und so
dass wir sie eben nicht weiter in
unserem land tragen vielen dank wir
gehen zur deutschen presse agentur vor
groß hallo frau groß
[Musik]
genau gucken und sehr wachsam sind und
auch übrigens natürlich die ärzteschaft
und die labore dass da eine hohe
sensitivität besteht auch bei den
menschen selber und deswegen denke ich
schon dass die fälle relativ früh
erkannt werden und maßnahmen ergriffen
werden können welche maßnahmen das jetzt
genau sind das muss wirklich vor ort
unter abwägung der gesamten situation
entschieden werden
und dafür sind die gesundheitsämter da
und gucken sich das sehr genau an und
ich habe da eigentlich auch großes
vertrauen dass die das gut machen
das sind wirklich hoch qualifizierte
leute die die lage vor ort gut kennen
und die sehen können viel besser als wir
wo treten die fälle auf welche
bevölkerungsgruppe ist aktuell betroffen
gibt es einträge in andere gruppen oder
nicht wo sind unsere urahnen population
wo sind unsere risiko populationen wie
müssen wir die schützen und die nicht
und dass die eine abgewogene haltung
haben und die maßnahmen
situationsgerecht anpassen da bin ich
eigentlich sehr stark von überzeugt
deswegen möchte ich jetzt nicht sagen
das ist zu viel oder zu wenig sein das
ist wirklich lokal muss das entschieden
werden und ich bin da zuversichtlich
dass das auch sehr gut gemacht wird es
gibt auch einen engen austausch mit den
zuständigen landesbehörden die er auch
noch da sind
[Musik]
aktion betrachten und in manchen fällen
die wir jetzt wo auch unsere mitarbeiter
mit vor ort sind die wir jetzt sehen
das sind wirklich umschriebene
situationen wo man dann sich auf den
wohnblock fokussiert oder auf den
betrieb und wo ist dann gegebenenfalls
nicht unbedingt sinnvoll ist die gesamte
bevölkerung und maßnahmen zu belegen
aber an anderen stellen sagen sie doch
sicherheitshalber machen wir das und
verschärfen auch die maßnahmen lokal
wieder beginnt zu ap herr jordan werden
warum der virus sich vor allem in den
stacheligen ausbreitet 7
vor allem im bild neben zu stellen oder
ist eine kalte feuchte luft
[Musik]
danke für die fragen das ist die erste
frage ist eine ganz wichtige frage die
interessiert sehr viele menschen ich
hatte ja auch eben gesagt dass auch in
anderen ländern den schlachtbetrieben
wir ausbrüche sehen wir können diese
frage noch nicht final beantworten ich
denke zum beispiel dass auch der
ausbruch in gütersloh
diese frage wahrscheinlich besser
beantworten lässt wir gehen zurzeit
davon aus dass es ein sowohl als auch
ist wir wissen noch nicht genau wo was
konkret eine größere rolle spielt das
liegt auch an dem jeweiligen
schlachtbetrieb und an den wohl
verhältnissen der mitarbeiter an den
entsprechenden stellen also sicher ist
natürlich dass wenn man beengt wohnt und
in engen räumen ist dass das generell
eine situation ist so ein virus einfach
leichter übertragen wird das ist
prinzipiell so das ist eine grundregel
gilt für alle
wohnverhältnisse es gibt aber auch
hinweise dass am schlachthof zwei
aspekte für eine übertragung eine
größere rolle spielen können das eine
ist tatsächlich wie sie sagen die
temperatur dort wird gekühlt um das
fleisch auch kühl zu halten und diese
temperatur keine rolle spielen und ein
anderer faktor den wir aber auch nicht
gering einschätzen ist derjenige dass es
eben dort auch zur bildung von aerosolen
kommt es ist ja dort auch oft feucht und
es kann doch zur bildung von aerosolen
kommen dann hängt es auch davon ab wie
eng die einzelnen mitarbeiter zu
einander stehen also das ist eine offene
frage
es wird ein wahrscheinlich beides dazu
beitragen mit je nach den verhältnissen
ist das eine oder andere vom von
größerer bedeutung der zweite punkt den
sie ansprachen bezüglich der app das
kann ich ihnen noch nicht sagen
die app ist erst vor einer woche
gelaunched wir lernen ja da immer weiter
wir sehen dass wir werden das in kürze
erfahren wir berichten auch darüber ich
weiß nur dass auch bestimmte tanz
angefordert wurden wir wissen aber nicht
wie viel das ist das werden wir in
zukunft auswerten geben sie uns da noch
ein bisschen zeit die ist glaube ich war
genau heute vor einer woche haben wir
die apps gelauncht wir gehen zur die
tagesschau ja gut man kann sich ja wir
haben sie gut ja ich habe gerne mal die
hotspots ansprechen die eben auch schon
diskutiert wurde angesprochen wurden
besonders jetzt bei dem fleisch bei dem
fleischverarbeiter im kreis gütersloh
reicht es denn aus ihrer sicht aus da
noch mal nachgefragt herr wieder
nachweislich infizierte und deren
angehörige in quarantäne zu schicken
oder wo ist ein punkt erreicht wo
vielleicht auch lockdown im gesamten
kreis nötig wäre vielleicht auch in
vergleichbaren reichen da diese
grenzwerte von neuinfektionen pro
100.000 einwohnern aus oder wo sagen sie
da müssten muss man dann eben verhindern
dass der virus oder das virus weiter
getragen wird in die allgemeine
bevölkerung und eben auch von der
lokalen situation dann vielleicht auch
wieder über landkreisgrenzen hinaus wo
würden sie da die grenze ziehen es wird
ja auch derzeit diskutiert na ja wir
wissen alle dass vor einigen wochen sich
frau bundeskanzlerin merkel mit den
ministerpräsidenten auf einen bestimmten
wert
einigt hat der so eine art faustregel
darstellt wenn man reagieren muss kann
ich nur sagen dass in diesem landkreis
ja auch reagiert wurde
ich kann mich aber nur den ausführungen
von frau rexroth nochmal anschließen das
muss vor ort entschieden werden
das ist wirklich sehr sehr wichtig denn
nur eine zahl alleine ist noch nicht so
aussagefähig sondern man muss sich das
geschehen vor ort betrachten ist es eben
eingegrenzte aus oder ist es ihr in die
community übergegangen das wird jetzt
alles intensiv untersucht vielleicht
nochmal die ausführung von frau rexroth
in den richtiges licht gestellt vor
rexroth leid in unser krisenzentrum das
heißt sie ist die frau die seit monaten
also diese intensiv das krisenzentrum
begleitet sie auch wöchentlich und
mehrfach wöchentlich telefonkonferenzen
mit den sogenannten solchen referenten
der länder durch für das heißt rexroth
ist wirklich sehr sehr nah am puls und
hat nicht nur ein gutes gefühl sondern
eine menge erfahrung und wissen wie die
einzelnen untersuchungsämter die
gesundheitsämter wie die einzelnen
landkreise mit solchen ausbrüchen
umgehen und insofern kann nämlich ihrer
einschätzung nur wirklich vorbehaltlos
anschließen
es muss vor ort entschieden werden und
natürlich haben die verantwortlichen
auch im blick ob sich so was regional
ausbreiten kann das gehört alles zur
einschätzung dazu gibt aber keinen grund
zu glauben dass das nicht auch mit der
nötigen wirklich überzeugung und
ernsthaftigkeit gemacht wird denn ich
will es noch mal sagen das ist ja eine
pandemie in einem ausmaß wie wir sie in
den letzten 100 jahren nicht gehabt
haben und ich denke jeder ist sich
bewusst dass sich das virus eben relativ
leicht aus behalten können vielen dank
wir gehen zu herrn wackelt reuters
regionalen der neuen normalzustand
bieten wir jetzt haben auf der einen
seite immer noch einige
schenken weiterhin werden zum anderen
aber mehr lokal begrenzte gegenmaßnahmen
es ist jetzt der normalzustand in berlin
zum nächsten monate haben so lange
bekannten stattfinden würde also in die
zukunft gucken ist immer schwierig weiß
nicht was vorweg oder ob sie nicht
ergänzen wird aber im ja ich kann mir
relativ schlecht vorstellen dass wir gar
keine fälle mehr haben in den nächsten
monaten sondern nach wenn man das
betrachtet wie es in den letzten wochen
gewesen ist wenn wir auch im auge haben
dass es ja irgendwann auch wieder ein
herbst geben wird wir werden
kontinuierlich dieses virus im land
haben und wir haben ja immer gesagt wir
wollen die anzahl der fälle so weit
runter drücken und das ist dieser
ausgezeichnete erfolg den wir momentan
haben denen wir wirklich den
gesundheitsämtern in erster linie und
den mitmenschen zu verdanken haben die
die master mitgemacht haben wenn wir die
ganze zeit die fallzahlen niedrig halten
dann gelingt es uns eben ausbrüche lokal
einzudämmen und zu beenden und das wird
so bleiben
und je besser uns das gelingt die
sensitiver wie sind die aufmerksamer die
menschen sind also müssen wirklich alle
mitmachen wenn man krank ist dass man
auch zu hause bleibt und eben sich eher
testen ist wenn man früher zum arzt geht
usw
ich denke das ist der normalzustand in
der nächsten zeit die aha regeln
einhalten wachsam sein sehr reaktiv sein
und schnell dann sich selber auch in
quarantäne begeben wenn man krank ist
und wie schnell beim arzt vorstellen
oder telefonieren und testen lassen ja
das wird ihr die die neue normalität
sein
für die nächsten wochen und monate
vielen dank berlin zur bild zeitung herr
reichel
wir hatten ja wir haben sie gut also
wieder sie selber haben vorhin von mir
angesprochen es gibt auch anzeichen aus
südkorea allerdings gibt es jetzt
weltweit schon die zweite welle ist das
eine zweite welle und wenn ja wie
wahrscheinlich ist
das auch in deutschland also was
wirklich wichtig ist zu verstehen dass
wir immer jedes lokale geschehen auch in
den lokalen kontext betrachten müssen es
gibt tatsächlich nach unserer
einschätzung im iran eine zweite welle
dort waren zwischendurch die fallzahlen
sehr stark gesunken und das ansteigen
das spricht für eine zweite welle aber
in südkorea etwa dort gehen wir davon
aus dass es eine erhöhung ist von
fallzahlen ob das schon der beginn einer
zweiten welle ist dass das wir können
wir noch nicht sagen wir denken dass
nicht das ist ein peak also eine eine
eine erhöhung wieder
ob das die zweite welle ist weiß ich
nicht also ich glaube so weit können wir
uns dann noch nicht einlassen ich hatte
auch selber vor kurzem noch mal wieder
die gelegenheit mit mark rein von der
weko zu sprechen
er schätzt dass auch er als einen peak
ein als der beginn einer zweiten welle
wir müssen da die fallzahlen auch im
auge haben in israel ist es tatsächlich
so dass dort eine reihe von fällen
auftauchten starke zunahme hier sind
etwa 40 prozent der fälle hängen im
zusammenhang mit mit schulen mit kindern
hier werden die israelischen behörden
natürlich auch sehr wachsam sein
dort wurde viel gelockert man man schaut
sich das dann in ruhe an hier weiß ich
nicht ob auch von einer zweiten welle
schon reden können aber ich glaube was
ganz wichtig ist also eine zweite welle
kann eben immer kommen und natürlich
kann die theoretisch auch in deutschland
kommen
ich bin aber sehr optimistisch weil die
menschen bei uns das wissen
und weil die menschen sich nach wie vor
vorsichtig verhalten und wenn wir eben
nach wie vor auch keine
massenveranstaltung zu lassen dass wir
diese zweite welle verhindern können
also ein wichtiges mehr zu sagen wir
wissen ja inzwischen wie wir sie
verhindern können wir haben hier gezeigt
wir kennen die werkzeuge und mit den
werkzeugen die war auch zurzeit haben
auch ohne impfstoff auch ohne
therapeutische können wir sind wir in
der lage diese zweite welle zu
verhindern das liegt nicht in unserer
hand in unserer verantwortung können wir
schaffen
vielen dank wir gehen zur n-tv herzstück
für nahtlos daran an
sie sagt schon zwei tabelle 1 anna
lieblingsthemen und viel sagen ja es gab
nicht mal die erste welle ich weiß hat
uns gut verhalten haben aber wie lange
noch mal vielleicht konkretisierte
wieder wie lange wollen wir diese aha
maßnahmen die sie geschrieben haben
aufrechterhalten solange es kein
impfstoff gibt und das co2 nicht spurlos
wieder verschwindet wovon sie
augenscheinlich nicht ausgehen ist es
eine frage von wochen von monaten
vielleicht von jahren und ergänzend dazu
was sagen sie zum thema schule öffnung
nach den sommerferien dazu gehen
zusammen
ja ich gehe davon aus dass es monate
sein wir hatten ja ganz klar an dass es
monate sein werden weil dieses videos ja
unser land nicht verlassen wird
und weil dieses virus ja auch in anderen
erdteilen unterwegs ist und natürlich
ist auch nach deutschland kommen kann
schon öffnung
das thema ist wichtig das ist uns allen
klar dass wir die schulen brauchen dass
wir schon öffnen müssen das ist wichtig
ist dass die kinder ihre bildung
bekommen und dass die familien entlastet
werden das ist ganz klar
aber diese schule öffnungen müssen eben
mit guten ideen konzepten begleitet
werden
und es gibt ja auch studien dahingehend
die uns dann zeigen werden wie der
impact sein wird wir begleiten das das
deutsche jugendinstitut ist hier
federführend da ist eine große studie
geplant die unter anderem auch das
robert koch institut mit begleitet das
hat für module diese diese studie und
zwei dieser module werden vom robert
koch institut maßgeblich mit beeinflusst
wir werden dann sehen wie die
auswirkungen sind ich möchte noch einmal
betont dass wichtiger ist aus meiner
sicht dass wir achtsam bleiben denn je
früher wir ausbrüche erkennen desto
schneller können wir sie eben eindämmen
und diese achtsamkeit werden wir noch
monatelang brauchen ja da wenig
festverlauf kurze nachfrage monaten also
wahrscheinlich ins nächste jahr hinein
kurze nachfrage weil sie sagen dass ich
los ist ja geld noch unterwegs müssen
wir uns darauf einstellen auch
erhebliche reise einschränkten haben
also vor allem eigenen
reiseeinschränkungen wenn ich an
infektionsgeschehen und südamerika denke
dass man sich da wirklich
die lockerheit die man bisher kannte was
es durch die welt fliegen angeht nicht
beibehalten wird kann es gibt ja die
einschätzung dass wissen sie vielleicht
es gibt die entsprechende information
natürlich auf den webseiten des
auswärtigen amtes wir haben diese
information ja auch verlinkt dort finden
sie klare hinweise ist auswärtige amt
das bundesministerium für gesundheit als
auch das bundesministerium des innern
die einigen sich dort regelmäßig durch
sind länder listen welche quarantäne
bedingungen gelten welche reise waren um
gegeben werden das wird kontinuierlich
aktualisiert und da müssen die menschen
tatsächlich drauf achten wenn sie reisen
ja wir gehen zur süddeutschen zeitung
vor ludwig zeichen dass eine einfach
bedeuten dass in sehr vielen landkreisen
steigen design sind oder bohren würden
sie das festmachen eine zweite welle
gibt ja klar es sind die fallzahlen zum
einen und es sind natürlich die
geografische verbreitung der fallzahlen
wenn die zahlen wirklich wieder stark
nach oben gehen dann wird man irgendwann
von einer zweiten welle reden können wie
gesagt ich hoffe nach wir vor und ich
gehe auch davon aus dass er das zusammen
schaffen diese zweite welle zu
verhindern
die sprache noch pflegeheime 1 wir haben
ja unter anderem kontinuierlich auch
empfehlungen verfasst weil sich ob da
noch was ergänzen können will ich will
ich die zahlen nicht immer im kopf habe
aber wir haben ja kontinuierlich
empfehlungen ausgearbeitet und wir
testen ja strategisch unter anderem in
pflegeheimen und in altersheimen und
sowohl personal als auch teilweise
bewohner so dass man relativ früh wieder
einträge in diese sogenannten setting
sondern diese besonderen situationen
überprüfen kann und dann schnell
reagieren kann
in einen ein großer schlüssel zum erfolg
ist also diese achtsamkeit immer im
hinterkopf zu haben dass eine infektion
wieder in eine solche umgebung
einbringen kann und das heißt die
menschen müssen also auf ihre
krankheitssymptome achten und das
weitere ist eben diese regeln
einzuhalten also gerade wenn es um das
moor tragen von masken geht und die
mitbewohner die die die angestellten in
bestimmten strategischen tests
einzubeziehen schnell infektionsketten
aufzudecken das ist eigentlich das was
wir tun und wenn das achtsame und
aufmerksam gemacht wird und dafür sind
die rahmenbedingungen geschaffen
diese tests werden bezahlt sie sind
finanzierbar es gibt genug kapazitäten
dann können wir ausbrüche in diesen
umgebungen schnell erkennen und schnell
unterbrechen
was würden sie denn sagen ab wie vielen
betroffenen kann ich so nicht sagen weil
es ja es hängt nicht nur von der anzahl
der landkreise ab sondern auch vom
gesamten geschehen von der anzahl der
fallzahlen von den instanzen vom erwert
es gibt eine haben wir diese drei großen
parameter kann ich auch gern noch mal
wiederholen
das eine ist die sogenannte transmission
also die übertragungsgeschwindigkeit
dynamik die wir messen mit bestimmten
zahlen inzidenz erwert anzahl fälle
betroffenen landkreise und zwei das
zweite ist die krankheit schwere die
davon abhängt wir wissen die krankheit
schwerer die krankheitsfreie natürlich
von der bevölkerungsgruppe abdi
betroffen ist ältere und risikogruppen
wie ein stärker betroffen und das letzte
ist letztlich die kapazität des
gesundheitswesens also wohl des
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienstes als
auch der krankenhäuser und aus diesen
drei faktoren zusammen wird man dann
einen schwellenwert irgendwann haben wo
man von einer zweiten welle
wir gehen zum handelsblatt frau gilt man
ja schon morgen ein technischer hinweis
ist vorab herr wieland vor allem frau
rexroth sind sehr leise frau rexroth
teilweise nicht zu verstehen und wenn
das auf die kollegen wechseln dann ist
es total laut so dass man immer hoch und
runter regeln muss aber das nur als
hinweis er will er sie haben gesagt mit
blick auf gütersloh die schlachtbetriebe
insgesamt dass sie davon ausgehen dass
sowohl eurozone als auch die temperatur
eine rolle spielen und sie haben den
herbst erwähnt was heißt das jetzt für
den winter müssen wir davon ausgehen
dass wir im winter rein
temperaturbedingt in deutlichen anstieg
kriegen wenn wir nicht massiv auftrags
bzw wesentlich vorsichtiger sein müssen
so weit es kälter wird also was im
winter immer geschieht ist ja dass wir
mehr infektionskrankheiten haben der
atemwege sowohl der oberen als auch der
unteren atemwege
wir werden wie jedes jahr auch eine
grippewelle bekommen dass das ist klar
und wir müssen natürlich sensibel zu
sein ich habe auch die hoffnung dass wir
dann durch die abstandsregel oder auch
das tragen von masken hoffentlich auch
die gesamtheit der grippe ins gesamte
gruppe last reduzieren können
ja wir müssen aufmerksam sein also wir
haben ja auch unsere ganzen zu wens also
überwachungsmethoden haben wir geschafft
wir sind auch dabei die gesundheitsämter
stärker zu unterstützen auch digital zu
unterstützen das meldewesen zu
beschleunigen
wir müssen all achtsam bleiben das ist
gar keine frage
und die herausforderung vor der wahl im
herbst und winter stehen ist sicher dann
herauszufinden wenn es einen anstieg von
atemwegsinfektionen ist im
herauszufinden was ist der verursachen
der erreger ja das ist ein punkt das
müssen wir im blick haben auch das
schärfen wir unsere diagnostischen tools
am institut unter anderem nach um die
noch breiter und genauer schauen zu
können
und ich habe natürlich auch die hoffnung
dass sich auch mehr menschen impfen
lassen gegen die grippe also wir
empfehlen
grippeimpfungen insbesondere für
bestimmte gruppen und ich hoffe dass wir
dann auch dadurch dass sich mehr
menschen impfen lassen
die last die krankheitslast grippe auch
mit reduzieren können vielen dank
wir gehen zur taz herr kreutzfeldt ja
schon wurden morgen wieder ich hätte
eine frage ob man ins besteige ich etwas
mehr weiß dazu in welcher situation sich
menschen anstecken oder die zahlen waren
jetzt in der letzten zeit so niedrig
dass man eigentlich erwarten könnte dass
die gesundheitsämter tatsächlichen fall
rückverfolgung gut hinkriegen aber ich
finde man sollte sehr wenig dazu nicht
mehr interessieren wissen sie was
darüber wie viele infektionen gibt
tatsächlich im schule in die viele im
öpnv auch in flugzeugen restaurants
reduzieren sich am arbeitsplatz wie
viele zu hause im gemeinsamen haushalt
und da irgendwas erfasst und vielleicht
auch weil man da zuletzt jetzt den
eindruck hat dass es sich immer mehr auf
prekäre situation sowohl am arbeitsplatz
als auch im wohnumfeld konzentriert und
irgendwie außer geschlecht und alter
dass ihr immer angegeben ihren berichten
auch irgendwas so zu zur wohnsituation
soziale situation der erkrankten wird
das in irgendeiner form erfasst oder
weiß man da gar nichts ja ich glaube es
muss vor rexroth mich unterstützen
also ich hoffe sie hören mich ein
bisschen besser ich versuche etwas
besser ans mikrofon zu sprechen
also sie sagen ist aktuell sind das ganz
stark die sozial prekären wohnumfeld
also armut was auch einfach insgesamt
gesundheitsrisiko ist und eben auch ein
risiko für diese 19 erkrankungen das
muss man schon sagen das erfassen wir
aber nicht in unseren meldedaten das
kriegen wir durch die information von
den ausbruchsgeschehen zusätzlich über
die ausbruchsgeschehen wir erfassen über
die menschen die fälle wie wir sie
nennen
nur sehr wenige genau definierte
gesetzlich festgelegte dinge auf
bundesebene
natürlich liegen mehr informationen in
den gesundheitsämtern vor aber auch aus
datenschutz ganz klar
wir erfassen alter geschlecht ungefähr
wohnort aber wir erfassen nicht die
staatsangehörigkeit wieder fassen
auf jeden fall nicht die
religionszugehörigkeit die sprache die
ethnie diese dinge erfassen wir auf
bundesebene nicht aber trotzdem können
wir das schon sagen eben aus diesen
zusammenhängen aus dem
ausbruchsgeschehen die in letzter zeit
dominant sind dass das armut ist dass
das sozial prekäre verhältnisse sind die
hier sehr förderlich zur ausbreitung von
coop 19 beitragen und die im grunde der
wurzel also die wurzel des übels hier
auch in diesen feldern sind empfängern
sind sie fragen nach öffentlichen
nahverkehr nachschulen nach haushalt das
erfassen wir zum teil über ausbrüche wo
es bekannt ist da können wir schon sagen
dass viele übertragungen im haushalt
natürlich stattfinden
aber eben auch viele das bricht mir ja
auch in heimen auch
erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen unterkünfte
für asylsuchende sind betroffen
es ist häufig schwierig wirklich den
infektions ort zu ermitteln
jemand war eben in der schule jemand war
im öffentlichen nahverkehr jemand war zu
hause und dann zu sagen an welchem ort
wirklich die übertragung stattgefunden
hat bei coop 19 das ist in sehr vielen
fällen tatsächlich ausgeschlossen
dennoch versuchen wir die wähler schon
gesagt hat unsere instrumente danach zu
schärfen da ist auch mehr einen
rechtlichen möglichkeiten geschehen so
dass wir das den infektions ort das
umfeld versuchen künftig besser auch auf
bundesebene zu erfassen und dann
irgendwie es natürlich auch auswerten
und ausweisen
dann gehen wir zu früh das war
pharmazeutische zeitung
[Musik]
es wird so wolle der kinder und der
schulhof immer sitzt das
infektionsgeschehen angeht denn in
hessen zum beispiel sind die
grundschulen ja wieder komplett geöffnet
und das minister lord hatte das auch
damit dass kinder hier sogar an dem mini
also infektions bremser hier wären
und genau da wollte ich würde mich ihre
einschätzung interessieren wie
gefährlich oder ungefährlich das jetzt
ist und dann gerne auch nochmal update
zu den studien also was ist mit der
kupferzell studie gibt ergebnisse dann
sollte es doch eigentlich diese woche in
rosenheim noch mal losgehen
und was ist das findet ihr diese erwähnt
hatten mit dem deutschen jugendinstitut
ja gerne also zu kindern gibt es eine
relativ klare einschätzung also kinder
können von diesem virus infiziert werden
kinder werden aber seltener krank und
schwer krank als dies bei erwachsenen
der fall ist
und es ist auch klar dass kinder das
virus ausscheiden und auch erwachsene
anstecken können allerdings in wie
effizient das ist das wissen wir noch
nicht der grund ist ganz einfach die
meisten daten die bisher erhoben wurden
haben ja stattgefunden in einer zeit wo
schulen und kindergärten geschlossen
waren
das heißt diese kinder hatten ja gar
nicht die möglichkeit quasi sich in
ihren gruppen anzustecken und dann die
das virus in die familien zu tragen
insofern ist also die effizienz der
übertragen ist ein v6 mit korrigiert
mich
so in die effizienz übertragen ist noch
nicht so ganz klar gesagt kinder können
infiziert werden kinder erscheinen virus
außen können auch andere anstecken ihre
zweite frage zu den studien ja sie sind
immer alle sehr ungeduldig das kann ich
auch verstehen aber die können uns
glauben dass wir diese daten ja auch
wirklich fundiert erheben wollen und wir
möchten auch nicht mit mit
zwischenergebnissen sie belästigen die
dennoch große interpretationsspielräume
lassen
wir führen insgesamt vier verschiedene
große studien durch wir sind bei vielen
anderen studien italiener die vier
großen studien die sie interessieren
nicht mal gerade es sind zum einen drei
studien die sich mit dem antikörper
status befassen da gibt es eine studie
wo wir blutspende proben nehmen über
ganz deutschland verteilt immer so
bestimmt ein paar hundert proben für
bestimmte regionen die wir auf
antikörper positivität testen dafür
benutzten wir den elisa von der firma
euroimmun und alle die proben die
positiv getestet werden werden im neu
traditionsfeste nachgeprüft
das zweite sind die sogenannten hot
spots studien unter die eine haben die
kupferzell genannt ich glaube da haben
wir schon ab 1000 oder 2000 100 proben
etwa genommen das hat etwa drei wochen
gedauert da waren ja vor ort ich glaube
mehr als 20 mitarbeiter des
robert-koch-instituts also sehr
umfänglich aber wir nehmen hier nicht
nur blutproben sondern wir machen auch
intensive befragungen auch zum
sozioökonomischen hintergrund das sind
sehr aufwendige studien die also
ausgewertet werden müssen und gerade
werden die blutproben untersucht und wie
gesagt die müssen validiert werden durch
reaktionstests das ist alles in der
mache die dritte große studie
das sind sogenannte repräsentativen
querschnittsstudie die laufen bis ins
nächste jahr rein und da gibt es auch
noch gar keine ergebnisse von also der
in alle noch ausgewertet
diese studie mit dem deutschen
jugendinstitut ist eine umfängliche
studie die zahl habe ich leider nicht
mehr den kopf an 300 kann als 1 300
orten in deutschland oder 300
einrichtungen aber das deutsche
jugendinstitut ist hier federführend die
haben sicher mehr informationen hier
geht es genau darum zu schauen was
geschieht denn wenn die schulen geöffnet
werden gibt es infektionen wie über
laufende übertragungen und so weiter das
wird alles untersucht aber die laufen
natürlich erst an wenn die schulen
wieder öffnen
und da dauert es noch eine weile bis die
ergebnisse sind ich habe nicht im kopf
den zeitplan waren erste ergebnisse auch
freigegeben werden aber noch mal ist das
deutsche jugendinstitut
[Musik]
und jetzt also man nicht die letzten
ausbrüche in gütersloh gerrit bedacht
sind ja sehr rückläufig und das vor
allem der anteil eben der kinder und
jugendlichen der gestiegen ist
und ja wie bedrohlich das ist das muss
eben wirklich genau weiter beobachtet
werden
die gute nachricht an cobit ist ja dass
die kinder eben nicht schwer erkranken
und das ist wenig todesopfer weniger im
vergleich gibt unter den kindern
es ist ganz anders als bei der influenza
also wenn man sich da sorgen macht um
die kinder da kann man wenigstens im
vergleich zu anderer
infektionskrankheiten ein bisschen
weniger sorgen haben aber natürlich ist
dennoch da sind lehrer da sind betreuer
da sind erzieher die gehören zum teil
zur risiko population die haben
vorerkrankungen vielleicht sind etwas
älter und das macht vor ort schon sorgen
und das ist im moment wirklich noch
nicht abschließend klar wie häufig dass
da auch zu übertragen kommt einzelne
übertragungen gibt es und wird es weiter
geben
wir werden dieses virus nicht
eliminieren ohne einen impfstoff das
kann man wohl sicher sagen und das heißt
es wird auf jeden fall weitere
übertragungen geben sicherlich auch mal
hier und da in schulen aber im moment
ist das nicht der bereich der uns die
allergrößten sorgen macht zum einen
ferien und in manchen bundesländern
schon einander noch nicht und eben zum
anderen die geringere volatilität der
kinder
im moment sind das eher betriebe
und prekäre wohnverhältnisse monatlich
allerdings auch kinder betroffen sind
und dann über diese situation auch
wiederum schulen und dann ist das sehr
arbeitsintensiv diese gesamten schulen
durch zu testen oder klassen durch zu
testen angehörige zu untersuchen
elternschaft und verursacht auch ganz
viel unsicherheit bei den betroffenen in
den gemeinden
vielen dank wir geben zur letzten frage
von planet international bittet
interview jakob hören sie mich ja danke
ich habe noch mal eine frage zu den
abstandsregeln also für einige branchen
wie die veranstaltungs porsche ist ja
die einhaltung der abstandsregeln
prinzip nicht möglich oder nur sehr
geringfügig was im moment ja viele
betriebe so in den ruin treibt könnten
diese abstandsregeln zahlen wenn
veranstaltungsorte kontaktdaten erheben
insbesondere in gegenden sag ich mal wo
es jetzt nur ein geringes oder gar kein
infektionsgeschehen gibt und dann hätte
ich auch noch eine kurze nachfrage also
die abstandsregeln von es gibt
wissenschaftlich bislang keine hinweise
daran dass für diese abstandsregeln
fallen lassen könnte dass das robert
koch institut wird entsprechende
empfehlung nach dem heutigen
wissensstand nicht ändern können das ist
ganz klar
ich denke aber es gibt auch eine ganz
ganz wichtige nachricht wie man
insgesamt das infektionsrisiko
zusätzlich verringern kann
das ist ja die tatsache die war ja auch
erst seit
wenigen wochen eigentlich klar erkannt
haben oder die herausgearbeitet wurde
die bedeutung sohlen und da kann man
natürlich zumindest die dass das risiko
senken indem man gute lüftungsanlagen
und filteranlagen in bestimmten städten
einbaut das ist sicher ein wichtiger
faktor um das risiko an over tagen zu
reduzieren wenn es jetzt sozusagen in
einer gegend keine infektionsgeschehen
gibt plädieren sie trotzdem dafür dass
die abstandsregel eingehalten werden
dass ich erst mal richtig
also das sind das sind unsere angaben
die sie müssen folgen das natürlich
immer vor augen haben das ist hatten wir
ganz am anfang auch besprochen
es sind natürlich die lokalen die
lokalen behörden die die von den
empfehlungen natürlich auch abweichen
können das tun sie ein häufiger mal aus
bestimmten gründen raus die sind
diejenigen die vor ort das büro teilen
es nicht können von empfehlungen
abweichen wenn das begründet ist und gut
begründet dann werden sie das auch tun
aber das ist eben das in der
verantwortung der lokalen behörden unter
der gesundheitsämter die sich mit den
fahnen genauer befassen werden und
müssen und das auch in der hohen
seriosität und mit der hohen
verantwortlichkeit auch tun sondern
vielen dank wir sind pünktlich kurz vor
elf zum ende gekommen und bleiben sie
gesund und es irgendwann mal wieder hier
im robert koch institut